so this next story is just more funny
than anything else
because we are obviously not going to
see donald trump's tax returns
but remember how donald trump has been
saying since 2015
that if it were up to him he would show
us his taxes
but they're under audit if and when
they're ever
no longer under audit he's going to
release his tax returns now
that never made sense anybody who could
think critically realized it never made
sense because obviously
not all of his recent tax returns would
permanently be under audit
and of course audits don't last years
and years but in any case
it was an excuse trump gave for not
showing his taxes
his personal attorney rudy giuliani
maybe it's his former personal attorney
at this point i don't know
he went on fox news and he said listen
there's got to be finality here
trump's taxes have been audited and it's
been closed
and we're moving on you can't now again
congress or investigators ask for
trump's taxes
he's indirectly saying we need a final
point on this because the whole audit
thing has been closed up well if the
audits are done let's see the tax
returns right
here is rudy giuliani himself saying it
they've been audited and it's fine
and these are now closed matters as far
as he's concerned
could make the argument that they have
no particularized need for it
you could also make the argument that
they are not investigating any
particularized crime
they have no reason to believe that
there's anything wrong with his tax
returns i mean all these tax returns
have been
by and large maybe not the last one but
all of them have been audited
all of them have been either passed on
or settled
and there should be some finality in
your tax returns
in other words we get audited we make a
deal we pay the government
you don't come after me forever for that
and also this is the president united
states
there are literally 400 4 000
prosecutors who can now come after his
records
i don't think the court ever thought of
that all these tax returns
have been audited and there should be
finality
rudy says you know you get audited you
make a deal
and that's it he is saying there that
the issue of the tax returns is over
because trump is no longer under audit
and he has moved on
he's saying you do the audit the audit
ends and that's it you don't keep
looking at the same returns that have
been audited
he's admitting that the audits are done
if they
ever existed now maybe even more
interesting there
is rudy saying trump's audits
aren't just done but they've been
settled when rudy says that
they've been settled it implies again
you know talk about self-inflicted
damage you settle audits and pay fines
when you've done something wrong on your
tax returns and rudy giuliani there
again just as an aside seems to say
not only are the audits done but they've
been resolved sometimes you know you pay
a fine and you move on
which seems to be an admission that
donald trump
has been deceptive enough on his tax
returns
you know you can always claim it was a
mistake but that he has had to pay fines
or make good or settle with the irs when
it comes to his taxes
it's stunning that this is not getting
more attention
it's stunning that a lot of people used
to respect rudy giuliani and again the
reminder is we're not going to see the
tax returns right
to be super clear trump was never going
to release the tax returns
the supreme court's decision isn't going
to get them released before the election
and the important thing for us is we
don't need to see them to know how to
vote in november it's not like we're
saying
you know i i on one hand i i don't like
these things trump has done and on the
other hand
this wasn't so bad but if i could only
see the tax returns i'd be able to
decide what to do in november
take solace in that even though we're
not going to see trump's tax returns
we don't really need to we already know
what we should be doing in november when
it comes to trump versus biden and i
think that's the if
you're looking for any positive takeaway
from any of this it's
we've got enough information to know how
to vote in november without seeing
donald trump's tax returns
tonight join me at 8 pm eastern
on youtube and twitch and facebook
for the third ever david pakman show
chess tournament
i'll be playing and streaming anybody
can play
community event no cost to play no
barrier to entry
it's completely free just register
at davidpakman.com chess that's tonight
to tuesday july 14th 8 p.m eastern i
will see you then
and of course remember that you can get
the daily audio podcast
every single day right around 3 p.m
eastern
on whatever is your favorite podcasting
app
spotify itunes google play podcast
pod bean if you will anyway wherever you
want to hear
it you can hear it one of our sponsors
today is helix
sleep and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled
about because i
sleep on a helix mattress at home and
it's just the perfect mattress one of
the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this
video